كما تعلم، تحدث أشياء كثيرة في بعض
الأحيان، تحدث أشياء كثيرة أحيانًا، تحدث أشياء كثيرة في
ممر رحلة عبر المحيط الأطلسي
مثل رحلة دلتا 198 على وجه التحديد من
أتلانتا إلى برشلونة، حيث تضطر إلى العودة
والقيام بهبوط اضطراري
بعد ساعتين فقط من الإقلاع، وإليك الطريقة
وصف الطيار حالة الطوارئ الطبية على متن الطائرة
لمراقبة الحركة الجوية، وبحسب ما
ورد لم يتمكن طاقم الطائرة من
احتواء حالة الطوارئ البيولوجية
بمنشفة ورقية ومطهر برائحة الفانيليا،
وبعد هبوط العجلات في
مطار أتلانتا، تم تنظيف طائرة الإيرباص A350
أندروود بشكل عميق ولم يكن هناك أي كلمة إذا كانت الرحلة
198 رقمًا.  هبطت طائرتان ولكن جميع
الركاب الذين كانوا على متن الطائرة، بما في ذلك الشخص
المسؤول عن المخاطر البيولوجية المذكورة، اشتروا
طائرة أخرى لبرشلونة بعد
تأخير لمدة ثماني ساعات، وقالت دلتا إن
رحلة دلتا 194 تعود جزئيًا إلى أتلانتا
بعد مشكلة طبية على متن الطائرة
وتعتذر مؤخرًا لجميع عملائنا
عن  تأخر في